no one expects to be hit with a 1 in 100
year flood
let alone two in two weeks
barely time to recover from the first
natural disaster Cyclone Gabrielle is
bearing down on New Zealand's North
Island packing Winds of up to 100 miles
an hour
225 000 people with no electricity no
phone
receding water revealing a deepening
disaster
silicon Gabrielle is the most
significant weather event New Zealand
has seen this Century the severity and
the breadth of the dim the damage that
we are seeing has not been experienced
in a generation
this morning we declared a National
Emergency for only the third time in our
history
with more sheep Than People a rescue the
poor sheep of the water wasn't really
that deep but they were just so
exhausted though I just had no energy
left
yeah so I just had to get my hand
they're not the only ones who need a
hand this is just over the top
really
um
you know like the thunder and lightning
and everything last night was just
horrific so but the devastation is just
oh it just makes you makes you want to
cry to be honest very upsetting
North Islanders from Auckland to Napier
and Hawke's Bay confront another climate
catastrophe
and batten down the hatches until the
next one
Nicole Johnston Sky News